ladies and gentlemen a very good evening
to all of you it's a great pleasure to
be here at the Emmanuel Center this
evening to welcome one of our most
popular exports who we have been in a
sense privileged to send over the United
States but to bring back on regular
occasions to talk to us about history
and that is of course professor Neil
Ferguson currently of Stanford
University but recently of the parishes
of Harvard and New York as well you will
know of course that Neil Ferguson has
written on a variety of topics many of
them with very punchy one-word theses to
start with civilization empire Colossus
and then the big names of the 18th 19th
20th century's Rothschild Warburg and of
course Kissinger the biography of whom
Neil is currently in the middle of of
writing but he is today come to us to
talk about a rather different set of
ideas in his new book the square and the
tower which is subtitled networks
hierarchies and the struggle for global
power and I was struck by a story that
you tell quite early on in the book Neil
in which you say that you were to some
extent put onto this topic by a
realization perhaps at a certain age and
a certain stage in the academic career
that you were extraordinarily well
connected and networked
but you felt that as an Ivy League
professor you still had no real power
now as an academic myself I can
sympathize with having no power even
though I can't claim to be in any way
well networked but I'm sure that wasn't
the only reason that you chose to write
this book what was the reason that this
particular topic took you up so strongly
well first of all can I just say what a
pleasure it is to be back here on this
stage where I think two years ago and
Roberts and I were talking about the
first volume of the Kissinger biography
it was partly writing that biography
that made me think about networks in a
more systematic way than I'd ever done
before we might talk about this later
and Rana but I have a hypothesis for
Volume two of Kissinger which is that he
went from being a Harvard professor to
being at one time perhaps the most
influential perhaps the most powerful
man in the world in the 1970s through
his network and the hypothesis that his
network really mattered is one that I've
vaguely is slightly tested out in this
book so I was thinking about networks
then of course I moved to Stanford just
about it a year ago and if you want to
think about modern networks the ones
made possible by the technology of the
Internet
there's really no better place and I
should tell you a somewhat discomforting
tale when I arrived at Stanford and
started talking to people in Silicon
Valley which is right next door about
what I do they kind of looked quite
bored surely not and you know the guys
and the t-shirts were like looking at
the phones and the Apple watches and I
realized that for these people history
began with the Google IPO or maybe the
founding of Facebook and all the stuff
that I was interested in was essentially
the Stone Age as far as they were
concerned and so I would kind of try
these conversations out you know there's
a lot that you could learn from that
kind of thing and people would look
completely zoned out so I was motivated
to write the book partly by a sense that
Silicon Valley had the Henry Ford theory
of history namely that history is bunk
irrelevant to them they had nothing to
learn from it because their technology
was so awesome what could possibly stand
in its way so the book was but partly
motivated I think by desire to think
through hypotheses about networks but
maybe more motivated by a desire to show
Silicon Valley that history applies to
them just as much as it applied to Wall
Street ten years ago when I was writing
the ascent of money
males Neela that's what's behind the lot
the broad claim on the back of the book
where it says what if not really thought
about history was wrong nobody should
ever be held responsible for what is on
the back
of his book any more than one should be
held responsible for the headline that's
put above ones articles in the newspaper
you know that Rana
well in that case we went heard his man
is not under oath when he signs off on
the blurb on the dust jacket well in
that case Neal we won't hold you to a
quote from someone else in The Guardian
that you're far too glamorous to be an
academic we'll take that as being fun
well it's a low bar I'm just saying
Touche very much to Shane let's get to
the idea and it is a big idea that
underpins the book and it's not just
about networks we've been using this
term quite a bit already and I think we
want to dig into it more deeply but also
about the contrast between that and
hierarchy and the point that you make
quite early on and you push very hard is
that historians as a profession broadly
speaking have been looking at history
through one particular framework too
much and another framework not enough it
would that be right I think that is
right of course we need to be nuanced
here but broadly speaking hierarchical
structures like states or armies or
corporations have attracted a
disproportionate amount of attention
from the historical profession you can
see why that would happen one
characteristic feature of large
hierarchical structures is that there's
usually an archives Department you know
state even a relatively small state even
a relatively poor state has an archive
and that is where historians tend to
converge even those historians who set
out to write social history or history
from below and a whole generation maybe
two generations of historians have tried
to do that usually ended up in the
archives whether they liked it or not
Richard Evans who was a pioneer of
social history and labor history ended
up writing the history of cholera in
Hamburg from the archives of the Hamburg
state so the problem with that approach
is that you're tending to overlook the
much more in four
all structures which I'm pulling
networks for short but should really
call distributed networks informal
organizations that are less likely to
keep detailed records of their
activities or if they do less likely to
keep them in one place so I think
there's a bias in historiography broadly
speaking over not just the last 20 years
but the last 200 years in favor of
states and the people who run States or
even just the people who are governed by
States and too little attention has been
paid to networks and problem which is a
really important one is that that has
left the field of network history to the
conspiracy theorists to illustrate this
point when you go home Google the
Illuminati or for that matter the
Rothschilds
I think something they're doing it right
now in fact here in the hall we're not
allowed to Google while we're talking
put those devices away at once but the
the Illuminati are a great example of a
network that for many years eluded
serious scholarship would you say this
is a sort of idea that in the 18th
century a variety of largely
enlightenment figures came together in a
massive conspiracy to try and control
the world and their influence in this
conspiracy theory are supposedly lasted
for the 200 years ever since this this
is one of the most potent conspiracy
theories out there has found its way
into the literature of such luminaries
as Dan Brown I think they're in The Da
Vinci Code but it's much worse when you
when you get into the websites that
purport to tell the history of the
Illuminati you enter the strange
parallel world of conspiracy theory
which we as academics are sort of
repelled by we we don't really want to
go anywhere near those people because
they're so disreputable but that means
we slightly leave the Illuminati and
other similar organizations say the
Freemasons in the hands of the
conspiracy theorists I mean I can
remember John Roberts at Oxford saying
you couldn't write the history of secret
societies in the 19th century you could
only write the history of what people
had said about them and that meant that
all these different network type
organizations were written about in an
entirely lurid
style going right back to the late 18th
century which blamed them for everything
you know you you name it there's a
literature that blames the Illuminati
for it or if not the Illuminati the
Rothschilds and if not the Rothschilds
the build up let's not indulge any
conspiracy theories but let's say you
know supposing we were frankly rather
large seminar group working the
professor Fergusson at Stanford and
you've just made that point isn't the
first thing that someone's going to come
back to you if they're trained to be a
historian to say well it's all very well
to make this critique there's a great
deal to it but what is it in terms of
sources and methodologies we should be
using to uncover this hidden history
surely the point about that history is
that it is hard to recover and that's
why people haven't ridden it hard but
not impossible
in recent years a tremendous group of
scholars in Germany have written a
serious history of the Illuminati which
did exist that really was a radical
enlightenment secret order founded in
the 1770s designed to promote the ideas
of the more radical parts of the
Enlightenment and it its strategy was to
penetrate the existing structure of
Masonic lodges they were kind of
infiltrating Freemasonry that the lodges
turn out to have quite extensive records
but no major to the society then you're
basically saying we're going back to a
different sort of institution and their
archives that's more a question of
looking harder for archives rather than
a different method I think it is bad
because clearly you can't do anything
without some source material the
characteristic feature of network
organizations is that there is source
material but it's very widely dispersed
because it's a network another good
example which is actually going on at
Stanford right now is the way in which
the Enlightenment itself can be
understood as a network phenomenon how
do you do that well you look at the
networks of correspondence and
publication through which Enlightenment
ideas spread and this has really become
quite an ambitious project in effect to
graph or map the intellectual revolution
of the 18th century and in the book I I
actually depict one of the products of
this
enterprise a map of Voltaire's
correspondence I got quite excited by
this tool because you can in fact plot
all kinds of graphs showing how exactly
the great intellectuals of the 18th
century communicated their ideas to one
another so it is doable to write the
history of networks but you need
somewhat different techniques and I want
to go to a very specific example Ament
and possibly one of the most important
ones in the book but just to drive the
point home again if we were sitting
amongst your historical colleagues your
historian colleagues at Stanford or
Harvard or elsewhere wouldn't they tap
you on the knee and say Neal in the end
what you're describing actually is the
kind of social history that people have
been doing for decades now they're
talking about trade unions forming
before the training is existed
suffragettes moving together illegally
and not being able to record what they
do these are in the end the sorts of
histories of people who haven't left
behind an archival record but which
people have been reconstructing through
oral histories to other sorts of sources
for some time is there really anything
different yes there is because although
there were all kinds of efforts in that
direction going back decades
no historians until very recently
understood the first thing about network
science about the theory of networks and
until you have some theoretical
framework to think about a network it's
just a term you use casually and
everybody in this room will have said
that they have been networking at some
point in their lives we started using it
as a as a verb back in the 1980s but in
fact there is a complex and
sophisticated theoretical framework for
understanding networks including the
network in this room so we could
actually graph the network of people in
this room with a relatively small amount
of data from each of you and we could
work out the structure of the network we
could work out who was most closely
connected with whom we could work out
who was the best connected person which
had used measures like betweenness
centrality to figure out which person in
this room in fact was the most important
heart
of the network of course it's me but I
think that God means six degrees of Neil
Ferguson this is a three point five
seven degrees it turns out because it's
no longer six degrees of separation so
the problem with a lot of what you just
talked about is social history is that
unwittingly historians were writing
about networks I used to do this I would
talk about networks when I was writing
the Rothschild book I would say well
there was a network of agents of
correspondents and so forth but I didn't
realize that I was failing to analyze
the network structure and so a really
big part of the motivation for this book
was to say to my fellow historians
people you've been writing about
networks without understanding how they
work without using the tools of analysis
that you need it's not enough to write
social history and then say oh well they
were the proletariat they were the
bourgeoisie and I suppose that must have
been the aristocracy which is
essentially what social historians
inspired by Marx did for several
generations no it's much more
interesting than that what's really
fascinating is when you start
understanding the distinctive properties
of social networks through the ages the
fact that their structure is not that of
a lattice the people in this room are
not all uniformly connected a little bit
to one another any group of people will
turn out to have a really quite complex
network structure and that's what the
book tries to do very few historians
have got that in fact there's a small
and growing generation of people working
in this kind of way drawing on these
ideas which come from not just from from
social science but also from the Natural
Sciences
you know neural networks are an
important part of where we get network
theory from even physics has made a
major contribution almost the best book
I read about networks is by a man called
laszlo barabasi
brilliant book that's the stuff that
historians haven't really paid any
attention to well we shall now turn I
think to a very specific example it's
one of the most important ones in your
book and that comes from the early
modern period about 400 years ago around
the era of the
information and just a reminder of
course that the Reformation is very much
on our minds in the current year because
it's 500 years since Martin Luther
basically put pinned up his precepts on
a church door opening the great rift in
European Catholicism and bringing out
bringing about what we now think of as
the birth of processed Protestantism
along with that comes a variety of
changes both in messages and Technology
and Neil your book does a great deal to
argue that the Reformation and the
technological and social and religious
revolution that comes with it is
actually a really important period in
terms of networks yeah there's some
terrific work on this which shows the
ways in which the advent of the printing
press in the 15th century set in to
motion what became one of the greats
intellectual religious revolutions of
all time the Reformation if Martin
Luther had did what he did in 1517
without the printing press he would have
been just another obscure chargrilled
heretic but because because Luther very
quickly was able to get his message out
about what was wrong with the the Roman
Catholic hierarchy through this amazing
network of printing presses all over
North Western Europe they could not stop
Luther going viral and this is a really
important insight there haven't been
many periods in history why when
established hierarchical structures have
really been overwhelmed by a network
phenomenon it was really difficult to do
in any previous century but the printing
press allows Luther's message to spread
with astonishing speed now there's a
very good paper which I cite in the book
by man Dame ditmar who compares the ways
in which printing led to a dramatic
decline in the cost of a page and atom
attic growth in the volume of book
produced and this is very similar in its
shape to what you get when you map the
personal computers are explosive growth
in our time and the analogy I think
holds very good broadly speaking what I
argue is there have been two great ages
of network disruption empowered by new
technology one really starts in 1517 and
the other gets going in our own time in
the 1970s with the birth and and rapid
growth of the internet and the personal
computer that's really a critical
argument in the book because only by
reassessing the Reformation as a network
driven phenomenon can we begin to
understand the implications of our own
network revolution and I'll just mention
a couple to illustrate why this really
matters Luther thought that if he could
only get everybody to read the Bible in
their native tongue in the vernacular
they would have an immediate
relationship to God that would no longer
be mediated by a corrupt clergy and
everything would be awesome as they now
say in Silicon Valley there would be a
priesthood of all believers we would all
be Christians together problem solved
this is so like what people in Silicon
Valley have been saying for years would
happen if everybody was connected in a
planet where everything is connected
there will be you can ask mark
zuckerberg
about this a global community and that
vision of the global community suddenly
struck me is just the same as martin
luther's vision of a priesthood of all
believers except that it doesn't turn
out that way once you connected
everybody in North Western Europe to
Luther's vision of Reformation what
happened no not a general agreement that
he was a good guy
dramatic polarization some people say
yes you're right we're with you in fact
we want to go further than you this guy
Calvin has the right idea and then a
whole bunch of other people said there
absolutely no way let's do the
counter-reformation Reformation and so
Europe goes very rapidly
into a state of polarization and in this
polarized environment conflict escalates
and you end up with about a hundred and
thirty years of religious war so that
analogy seems to me to be a really
powerful one as we try to understand the
polarization of our own time and this
tendency for stuff to go viral not all
of it good
will get in a very short time to the
question of whether what we're going to
face 130 years of warfare in our own
period and I think everyone he'll be
very pleased to know what your answer is
to that question
sticking with Luther's time for a little
longer
you mentioned various things including
the use of the printing press and
technology to spread the Bible and of
course the use of the vernacular Bible
in local languages in English in German
and French and so forth was an important
part of that but isn't another important
part of the networking the shared use of
language this is also a time when there
is a commonality of the use of Latin in
this particular case I think also about
a part of the world in which I work in
terms of history and that's China where
of course we'd like to point out that
printing was invented rather earlier
than it was in in Europe and you also
have there and I know acknowledged that
in the book absolutely so and China is
something we'll also come come back to
you but thinking about sort of the
parallel period you also have there the
spread of commercial and merchant
culture because of the ability to print
and pass out these these messages
whether they're commercial or religious
Buddhist texts an example of that too so
how important is shared language as a
driver as a motor for your network
mechanism well it's it's hugely
important one can see that today if one
graphs the the world's online networks
the reading are two one is essentially
an english-based network which is run by
network platforms based on the west
coast of the United States and the other
is a Chinese Network and they're really
quite separate now because the Chinese
built their own network platforms and
there is remarkably little communication
across the borders there's some but but
not not anything like as much as there
would be if we all spoke and used
English and that also comes in
into the case of the Enlightenment where
there is a global conversation going on
in in French and English and those
people who are in that conversation can
use both those languages so I think
languages is crucial you can't have a
network which is going to succeed that
is that it's polyglot that's really hard
to manage and one of the things that
actually is an interesting content
occasion in your book when you talk
about the Enlightenment is that you
point out that some of the networks of
knowledge and I think you were thinking
there at the Scottish enlightenment
these thinkers like David Hume in the
early 18th century who put forward a
whole variety of social and economic
ideas actually when you do one of these
fascinating graphs that turn up over and
over again in the book they have quite
small networks of connection compared to
some of the other ones you've talked
about that's right
my heroes are really the great Scottish
thinkers of the Enlightenment and they
turn out not to have been anything like
as cosmopolitan in their reach as say
Voltaire and so I think one begins to
realize that the Enlightenment wasn't
quite as as global or cosmopolitan or
phenomenon as we had thought a lot of
these networks turn out to be quite
custard in in national communities most
of Voltaire's correspondents were in
fact French and yet we do have from
somewhere coming out this idea that the
Enlightenment does change the way that
we think about ideas of rationality
about secularism about the way the world
works the Enlightenment still stands as
this period of the 18th century when
European thinkers recast almost a sort
of post religious world so if it's not
networks doing that what is the
mechanism that enables that particular
period to be ultimately influential and
successful
well the way I would think about this is
that Luther had began a succession of
network driven revolutions Luther
himself understood that once you could
print the Bible you could print anything
even he even argued that the Koran
should be printed in German he was
against its suppression arguing that if
it was printed then people could see the
error of of
this was a remarkably bold thing for
somebody to say in the 16th century
the Scientific Revolution didn't take
long to happen it was the next great
intellectual revolution clearly driven
by an international network the
Enlightenment I think follows the same
pattern you can be Benjamin Franklin in
Philadelphia and be plugged into a
conversation about ideas that is
happening in paris and in Edinburgh and
the Industrial Revolution rather less
glamorous but economically much more
important revolution that began in the
British Isles had the same character
although it involved quite different
people I'd say there was a kind of era
of networked revolutions that culminated
in the political revolutions in the
American colonies and in France and that
was the sort of high points of that
networked era that had begun in 1517 but
in the way the networks over reached
ideas of Liberty that worked pretty well
in the American colonies worked pretty
badly in the case of France which
plunged into a kind of bloody Anarchy
near Civil War in the 1790s so in the
book there's a really crucial turning
point which is Napoleon Napoleon is a
hierarchical figure who says the only
way we sort out this mess is that I
control everything and Andrew who was
here two years ago has done such a
terrific job on Napoleon's bunker really
wonderful biography showing what a
control-freak Napoleon is and the pony
ins attitude is the only way we fix this
is if I make every decision right then
so in power of the answer to that and I
imagine there may be some Napoleon fans
and the audience who'd like to speak up
for him during Q&A is that amongst other
things yes he conquers large parts of
Europe but he also introduces the code
Napoleon in other words shared ideas of
law shared ideas of understanding how
bureaucracy and rationality work that
helped create the mechanisms by which a
network could operate in other words
people can talk to each other in
literally the same language because of
Napoleon surely that helps not hinders
the network but let's not get too
fixated on the ideas the network
structure
is as important as the content of any
idea passing through the network that's
a really crucial point why do things go
viral
most people instinctively assume it's
because they're just really cool things
they're really kind of inherently
attractive and interesting but it turns
out to be the case that perfectly
interesting and attractive things don't
go viral and really bad things really
unpleasant things can go viral
witchcraft
went viral as well as the Scientific
Revolution Chief Thomas showed that many
years ago and that's because network
structure is really crucial it's as much
the structure of the network that an
idea or for that matter an actual virus
attacks that determines how far and how
fast it spreads what essentially
Napoleon said was these ideas are all
very well and good but the structures
gone haywire we need to restructure
France so that one person may is in
complete control and that was the
essence of the Napoleonic project
enlightenment despotism and I think that
seems to me like an enormous turning
point in historical development the
assertion that human society in fact
does need a strong authoritarian and
hierarchical structure in order to
function and I'd say for the next 200 or
so years that's a very powerful
attractive ideas a attractive
proposition that leads to the emergence
of evermore centralized states so
hierarchy basically wins somewhere
around about 1800 and becomes the
dominant structural form right the way
through the 19th and into the middle of
the 20th century
and that brings us in little while to
the subject of China which of course
shows very interesting characteristics
of both the hierarchy and the network
but before we get there let me take up
another thought that's driven by your
mention of Napoleon and that's the link
between hierarchies networks and power
and that I think inexorably brings us to
Henry Kissinger you
probably more time than anyone in the
Academy examining the life of Henry
Kissinger in details that you're
uniquely qualified to talk about him in
the chapter on Kissinger in your book
you talk about the way in which you come
to discover that you think that
essentially he's possibly the most not
necessarily the most powerful but the
most networked figure in modern politics
that there has been or ever will be why
that was that well this has to do with
what happened in the 1970s if you think
about what I said a minute ago the
napoleonic notion of one man in total
control keeps on repeating itself right
the way down to the middle of the 20th
century when you have the ultimate
expression of hierarchical power in the
totalitarian states that the Third Reich
the Soviet Union and most people
Republic People's Republic of China
Stalin is so completely controlling that
he knows every telephone conversation
that is going on and when he hears that
Isaiah Berlin has played paid a visit on
the poet Anna Akhmatova he persecutes
her and her family as punishment in the
Soviet Union there is no social network
possible that is not authorized by the
state by the 1970s the great
hierarchical States that had emerged in
the mid 20th century were beginning to
fragment they fragmented in a bunch of
ways but the United States found it
couldn't win a war in Vietnam and
plunged into a social and cultural
crisis which Americans are reliving
thanked thanks to Ken Burns his
documentary right now the 1970s is also
the time that the Defense Department's
so preoccupied with the mess in Vietnam
and much else that it just kind of
leaves these guys on the west coast to
build something called ARPANET which is
the beginning of the internet and do
whatever they like with it there's
there's no central control over the
innovations that produce the Internet
the Soviets have a project for an
internet but it's shut down by the
Finance Ministry so this is the scene
into which Henry Kissinger
enters Kazuto who had been an academic
was not a promising figure in the
beginning of the Nixon administration
most people assumed like the aging
indeed dying Dwight Eisenhower that he
would be at best a cipher for Nixon
within a few short years of sickness in
1969 he comes in as national security
adviser to newly elected Republican
President Richard Nixon within three or
four years the world generally agrees
that super K and that's how he's
represented on the cover of news
magazines is the most powerful indeed
the indispensable man that phrase was
used in a time profile and I try to show
in this book and I'll show it again I
think in volume two of the bog raphy
that that's because Kissinger understood
that the age of hierarchy was waning it
didn't really matter where you were in
the org chart you know the organization
chart that says the president's there
and the national security adviser is
there but the Secretary of State has
actually above him
Kissinger didn't care about the org
chart he despised bureaucracy and had
done since he was a young man
Kissinger realized that real influence
and maybe ultimately power too came from
your network and that is why he
compulsively launches with journalists
even hangs out with people in TV and
movies and build a network that's
ultimately global for me the key insight
was that one could actually graph that
network and establish not just
journalistically but rigorously that he
was the most important node in the
network that word node is crucial you're
all nodes I'm a node ran as a node the
relationship between Nana Iran and me is
an edge but that's essentially the not a
sharp one I hope that's a quite soft
edge of you know mutual academic respect
and degree of political hostility on
Runners side I imagine
because all Oxford Dons think I'm a kind
of wild-eyed consumer we're just jealous
they were just jealous there is that so
Kissinger you can show that Kissinger
was the indispensable man and I've done
it in the book with the help of a
brilliant student of mine Manny Rincon
we've graphed the Nixon and Ford
administration's we looked at all the
ways in which the the people within the
administrations interacted and found
that yes he really was after Nixon by
far the most important person in those
administration's so I think it's a very
useful tool and to go back to something
we were saying earlier other historians
need to make use of this kind of thing
because it's very revealing once you
formally graph a network it can often
turn out that the person you thought was
really important wasn't that important
and I give the example of the American
Revolution to back that up
there's a lovely paper if you're
interested in the American Revolution
that probably some Americans here
tonight it's a great story but the story
we tend to tell gives enormous
importance to Washington Jefferson and
of course since the musical Alexander
Hamilton but Paul Revere was way more
important Paul Revere than Joseph Warren
were the key people in the network that
made that revolution happen but that was
the man who famously made the ride from
Lexington to Concorde and was a sort of
key figure remains an iconic figure of
the American Revolution absolutely and
and the connectedness of Revere is
something that we can graph moreover it
turns out to be crucial that these key
nodes and the revolutionary network were
freemasons they were already in a
pre-existing network so that's the kind
of thing that I find really fascinating
and it's the kind of thing that you
won't find in most history books of the
revolution ok but let's stick with Henry
Kissinger for a moment Neal because
while I'm willing to absolutely admit my
jealousy of you I think all dawns are
much more jealous of Henry Kissinger who
managed to make you from the Academy to
to world domination because you talk
about the way in which the world
changing that enabled him to create that
network but the fact is that the people
who came afterwards Cyrus Vance George
Shultz you know Lawrence Eagleburger
other secretaries of state they were
distinguished people they had networks
of their own and yet the fact is that
Henry Kissinger has not been in a formal
American government office since 1977
and yet when anyone mentions a Secretary
of State an American diplomat Kissinger
is even now at the age of 94 top of the
list so there must be something
distinctive about him it couldn't just
be the change in terror at the time so
other people would have been able to do
that too I think that's a great
observation Rana you know China better
than me he's still the most revered
Western figure that's correct they're
even more than Mark Zuckerberg a little
bit more Xi Jinping will invite him to
come for private one-on-one meetings
Putin to it's extraordinary the extent
to which a man in his 90s is still
turned to at critical junctures such as
followed the election of Donald Trump
which took most international observers
by surprise and I think it would be
wrong for me to go to the other extreme
and say it's all about network structure
it's also the fact that in his
relationships Kissinger has this uncanny
ability almost to mind-meld to get
inside the psychology and even the
history of the person that he's sitting
opposite and this is something I did
write about him in vol 1 this ability to
put yourself empathetically
in the other person's shoes is a very
powerful skill that he has and when you
look at the relationships in his memoirs
for example that he mentions most
frequently there were people there with
people from completely different worlds
and was Sadat Cho and lie these were the
people that he formed very strong
relationships or the Soviet ambassador
Dobrynin so I think in the end the key
to to Kissinger's Network was not how
many shuttle diplomacy flights did he
take I think John Kerry and Hillary
Clinton thought
was the keys so they would always boast
about how many countries they've been -
no it wasn't the air miles that mattered
it was the way in which he built
relationships and I suppose the more
I've reflected on this the more I've
realized that the study of networks is
the systematic study of relationships
and it's the recognition that in any
organization any institution there
really are two maps there's the org
chart which tells you who you report to
and who reports to you and then there's
the network which is the real map and
people who work on organizational
behavior some of them at Stanford
Graduate School of Business routinely do
this for companies they'll go in and
they'll say you think you're in charge
we'll show you who's really in charge so
I think it was somebody who grasped that
the network's more important than the
org chart and I think that's generally
true you've talked about the way in
which different sorts of hierarchy and
different sorts of network have emerged
from the 1970s in an age when again
technology changes very considerably you
mentioned the ARPANET which of course is
the predecessor of what we now think of
as the world wide web and the Internet
and we now live in a time when what some
people have called Fang is dominant and
that stands for Facebook Amazon Netflix
and Google I have to say I have some
doubts and no disrespect to anyone from
Netflix here that Netflix may be in the
list because it makes the abbreviation
actually sound rather more more
pronounceable but nonetheless let's
include them in that you can have gaffer
if you prefer and add Apple in which is
better the European Commission likes
gaffer but it doesn't work as well on
the other hand the European Commission
doesn't like many of these organizations
very much but the question comes in
these were organizations that started
off that you mentioned Mark Zuckerberg
chief executive of Facebook wearing the
t-shirt in everyone's wearing their
baseball caps looking very very casual
in Silicon Valley making millions of
dollars these are supposed networks
social networks that actually are the
new hierarchies aren't they well that's
the paradox I mean in the end let's be
clear a hierarchy is just a kind
network this is not a dichotomy that you
should attach too much importance to a
hierarchy is just a network where key
edges are missing that force most nodes
to go through a central node whatever it
is they want and a network a distributed
network is one where there are more
edges in there no such obviously
dominant nodes so just to get that clear
that means it the paradox is in fact
resolved by network science if you
create a giant network with 2 billion
people which is what Mark Zuckerberg has
done more than 2 billion people now are
on Facebook half more than half the
entire population of the United Kingdom
are regular Facebook users on the
Facebook page once a month minimum if
you do that you are not creating a
lattice like structure in which
everybody is just a netizen equally
sharing ideas and posting thoughts and
liking stuff no the actual network
structure is profoundly unequal because
in almost all social networks there is
this extraordinary phenomenon of
preferential attachment when people join
the network when new people join they
want to be connected to some nodes much
more than others
they want to be connected to the nodes
that are ready really well connected so
all large social networks are
characterized by in fact a hierarchical
structure
Donald Trump has way more Twitter
followers than any of us not just a lot
more just orders of magnitude more than
most people in this room and that's the
characteristic feature of social
networks and it becomes more striking
the bigger they get but so that's part
one of my answer not just not just on
that Neil isn't wouldn't he be the case
in any modern era though that the
President of the United States would say
get millions more people watching him on
television then will be the case with
even you as you appear on television or
me who hardly ever does you know is
there any order of magnitude of
difference in terms of the quality
of that network as opposed to just
simply being someone who people pay a
lot of attention to well these are a
very it's a very different technology in
the end television networks were
centrally controlled there was a very
finite amount of programming that you
could watch say during the Nixon
presidency our networks are not like
that there isn't in fact central control
over what is posted on Facebook and
that's part of Mark unless you're a
muscle well unless you're an AW or for
that matter in China where there is
actually some kind of effective system
of state censorship what happens with
these networks is far more spontaneous
all those two billion people are posting
stuffs and liking stuff and it is that
as it's a spontaneous outcome of those
collective actions that produces what we
see online algorithms decide what is
going to feature most prominently not
people and that's a very different thing
from the big television networks of the
mid and late 20th century the second
part of my answer which is really
crucial is that unlike the great
networks created by the printing press
the networks created by the personal
computer the smartphone and the Internet
are very concentrated in their ownership
Johannes Gutenberg did not become a
billionaire in fact he was bankrupt at
one point and ended his life on a state
pension the people who built the social
networks of our time have become
billionaires they own the network's you
just use them and this is a very very
important difference between our time at
that time in our second networked age if
you'll forgive me calling it that the
network heightens the inequalities that
already exist in our societies the
richest men in the world and their men
are increasingly the people who own the
infrastructure and the the networks that
exist on the platforms
of the internet and the world wide web
and this is an astonishing state of
affairs because it has created a new
hierarchy as you rightly say rather this
is a critical argument of the book
there's a new hierarchy in town and it's
the hierarchy of Silicon Valley to the
people who run these companies there is
an astonishing sense of power but in the
last 12 months there's been a
realization that as they say in the
spider-man movies with great power comes
great responsibility and a great deal of
trouble too if you don't know how to
manage that responsibility
so of course Neal most of those if
probably all almost all of those Silicon
Valley internet billionaires would have
preferred Hillary Clinton have comprised
the United States and she didn't
so to their utter horror and it really
was it was really kind of fascinating to
watch up close they found that the
network platforms they'd created could
be used to achieve the opposite of what
they had intended it was not the Clinton
administration campaign that knew how to
use Facebook to target advertising in
order to secure the swing states
it was the Trump campaign it was Steve
Bannon and Jared Kushner
not to mention Russian intelligence but
we are in the midst of a great exposing
which is not over that is going to
reveal the extent to which Trump
campaign in a large way and the Russian
intelligence network in a small way used
Facebook and to a lesser extent other
platforms to achieve victory in the 2016
presidential election and I argue in the
book and I stand by it that Donald Trump
would not be President today if there
had not been Facebook and Twitter and
the other platforms that were used in a
conventional traditional American
election campaign he would have been
defeated because he would have been
outspent Hillary Clinton outspent Donald
Trump two to one more than two to one on
standard cable and terrestrial
television advertising he would have
lost so this was a huge
significant moment in American political
history I still don't think people
realize the extent to which it depended
on the use of Facebook in particular
well I think the realization in the
wider sense of the power is one of the
reasons why the one market who want to
call it that I think it is a market in
the world that doesn't fully conform to
this of course is China and there you
have an Internet nitta-san population
that is now about twice the population
the United States as a whole about 600
million and growing there are indeed big
dominant companies there Tencent Alibaba
Baidu but these companies are very much
hand in glove with the Chinese Communist
Party and make no particular secretive
and it's not something that they would I
think be ashamed of is that going to be
the alternative model of how the
networked society changes one where an
authoritarian state not only is not
submitted by it but actually coops it I
think that's right and then in the book
I aventure into your territory Ranna by
writing about what's happened in China
where Fang has failed to get its teeth
into the market despite every effort I
mean Facebook has tried Google has tried
they're all struggled and ultimately
ubers the most recent case they've been
rebuffed and in their place the Chinese
have built their own giant Internet
companies the bat has beaten the Fang
Baidu Alibaba $0.10 this means that
there's a parallel I mentioned it
earlier a parallel world of social
networks which is the Chinese world that
is not closely connected because there's
a Great Firewall of China around it to
the rest of the world which is
essentially Silicon Valley's this is
enormous ly important because it because
as you say Rana there is an intimate
relationship between the Communist Party
and the giant Network platforms there is
a unique opportunity here for a
government a system of government than
many people thought was on borrowed time
certainly in 1989 to consolidate its
power because never in history has a
government had such access to the data
of its
citizens as the Chinese government now
has it is something that even the most
dystopian visions of the mid 20th
century didn't approximate to know we
shall see what comes of it but my strong
impression is that the Chinese were
strategically brilliant to see the
threat posed by Silicon Valley and to
understand that they could co-opt these
technologies to strengthen their power
well in a moment we're gonna go to our
audience so I sure have a great deal
they want to bring to the discussion but
let me end if I may with a question that
comes from what you've just said but
goes back to the question of the way the
historical framework that the book
operates in because when all said and
done and I mean this is a supreme
compliment you are best known as a
historian and historian you know who
thinks big a lot of history perhaps
sometimes artificially has been thought
of as dichotomies so Reformation period
Catholics versus Protestants in Europe
in the 20th century the Cold War the
Communist world versus the capitalist
world are we seeing the beginning right
now really the early 21st century of a
world in which there may be essentially
two technologically enabled networks one
which is broadly the quotes liberal
capitalist world driven by the United
States but not wholly of the United
States and then one which is essentially
defined by what the Chinese are doing
and will we see that dichotomy that
relationship but separation operate for
years or indeed decades to come as a new
historical framework it's possible but
one thing that's very clear is that
Europe has a different vision of its
future the European Commission has
become increasingly aggressive in not
only taxing but regulating the big
American companies that is a battle that
is already underway and there will be
another battle coming soon which will be
the battle between the Trump
administration and Washington more
generally and Silicon Valley so I think
only the Chinese have really resolved
the tension between the network
platforms
the new networks and their new hierarchy
and the established hierarchies of the
mid 20th century states and I'm more
interested in at least in the short run
in how those divisions within the
Western world get resolved it's not
clear to me who wins in the United
States is it going to be Trump or is it
going to be citizens of the most
powerful publisher of content since
William Randolph Hearst probably much
more powerful than any newspaper tycoon
in history there's going to be a
collision there watch this space it's
already beginning and I do not know
because I really can't predict it how it
will how it will turn out one final
thought although I'm a networked kind of
person I always hated hierarchies from
school onwards and the more hierarchical
the hierarchy the more I hated it my
brief encounter with army life as a
cadet from the Glasgow Academy combined
cadet force was a horrible experience
about which I still have recurrent
nightmares I actually became an academic
when I realized that there was no
hierarchy and academic life in practice
although there might be one on paper
although I'm a kind of networks person I
don't think you can run the world on
networks and the vision of a world run
on networks is in fact a nightmare
vision so I conclude with a kind of
appeal for at least some hierarchy in
the world there has to be some hierarchy
in the international order and that's
why I point out that although you're
right there is potentially a dualistic
world of China V the rest
there's also world in which China and
the United States sit with three other
powers Russia France and this country in
a special place the United Nations
Security Council first amongst equals
permanently in a position of power over
other states so the great powers Liv and
another scenario which I prefer to yours
is one in which increasingly those great
powers realize that whatever the problem
whether it's cyber warfare all
potentially biological warfare
or nuclear proliferation or climate
change
they either hang together or are hanged
separately and that's the way I conclude
the book with the kind of appeal to to
hierarchy so I think there is a
tremendous amount there for us to digest
this evening I will say that you really
don't know what powerlessness is Neil
until you've been head of department at
a British I've watched and I think
that's one thing that you didn't manage
to get away from your time in the in the
UK right rightly so we have now very
large and I think very lively audience
here this evening at the Emanuel Center
and we have microphones I think going
round so could I please see any hands
from the audience with questions please
make them concise and proper questions
if you could - Neil Ferguson and we'll
pass them on and get his opinions I'm
gonna take two or three at a time just
to make sure that we get plenty in you
Jim and number one over there we'll
start with that and there's a three over
there on the seat you must be a tuner
soon and yep with one two three since
they're there splendid go ahead sir
thank you very much
is there a tendency towards groupthink
with networks very good very concise
question thank you for that groupthink
number two right in the other side of
the wall go ahead
yeah just picking up on professor
Ferguson's last point do you think
networks generally are corrosive of
democracy in that they're not
accountable or are they actually very
democratic or can they be both at the
same time excellent and let's take a
third one and then go to the go to go
back to Neil where's a number thank you
very much yep yeah do the size of
networks have a particular importance as
in the smaller the network the rate of
the premium of the network the people
inside it can organize themselves better
they can know each other they can act as
well more effectively so for example in
the 19th and 20th century the labor
movement the feminist movement the gay
rights movement all these network so to
speak faced intense hostility by the
bigger network the bigger hierarchy of
the culture but because they were
smaller and more organized they could
win in the end great questions each and
every one I'll take them
order groupthink is a great term here
because one of the characteristic
features of large networks that I
mentioned was the tendency for them to
self segregate into clusters the idea
that we'll all just be one big global
community is fanciful because in
practice what is happening on these
large networks is a self segregation
usually along ideological lines one can
see this in some recent work that's been
done on Twitter people who use Twitter
and retweet tweets tend only to retweet
things with which they are ideologically
sympathetic and so we have these
extraordinary far apart clusters of
retweets liberal retweets there and
conservative retweets there and the
result of that is because of the way
these platforms work we find ourselves
in echo chambers because the algorithm
keeps sending us things that it expects
us to like and agree with so groupthink
is endemic in large social networks it's
really one of the most unhealthy aspects
of the the network's world and this
encourage is something that we all have
innately which is our confirmation bias
once you've taken a position you start
wanting evidence that supports it rather
than evidence that contradicts it the
true scientist is Karl Popper long ago
argued is looking for the opposite he
wants to have his hypothesis disproved
but we're only human we'd rather have
the hypothesis proved so the networked
world encourages confirmation bias in a
way that is really quite frightening and
this leads on to question two these
networks and democracy they matter
hugely for the democratic process I
argued this evening and I mean it it
decided the outcome of what happened in
the United States last year and I think
it also decided the outcome of the
brig's that referendum it was actually
Dominic Cummings who pioneered the use
of targeted Facebook advertising to hone
the message of the leave campaign which
you say Dominic Cummings is one of the
major political strata
involved on the brexit side I think he
was the genius
if that's the word of Briggs's and he
was the one who understood that you
needed to use these tools to craft the
message to find out what worked and then
to bombard the key voters with it
Facebook data allow you to do that
Facebook data if you can get them allow
you to exactly target your message down
to the postal code so I I think beyond
the postal code down to all the personal
traits of individuals that Facebook has
been given by your because you gave mark
your data for free that's what you did
on the other side of that spectrum
actually Neal people have analyzed that
via the left-wing side that Jeremy
Corbyn Labour Party actually was much
better in the recent British general
election at using Facebook data than the
concern fact Jeremy Corbyn has four
times as many Twitter and Facebook
followers as Theresa May or Boris
Johnson four times now that is a bigger
margin of advantage on social networks
that Donald Trump had over Hillary
Clinton and his advantage was pretty big
so this for our democracy
has enormous implications because I
think it makes the probability that
Jeremy Corbyn will be the next prime
minister much higher than anybody in
Manchester appeared to realize or maybe
they did realize this week incidently
isn't it lucky that these letters up
here are projected so there's really no
danger that one of them will fall off
and turn me into eloping and keep
drinking the water near we don't want
your voice to give out either less I'm
going to try not to descend into
helpless coughing finally
and nobody I hope going to give me an
unemployment slip no no you're okay for
the next 20 minutes wouldn't it
sighs so sighs I forget where the person
who asked the size matter over there I
think yes so size matters I think in the
opposite way from the way you thought or
frame the question Metcalfe's law
Metcalfe's law says that the value of a
network grows with the size of the
network so the more nodes you get to
connect up the more valuable the network
is which is why he has Mark Zuckerberg
has furiously chased additional Facebook
users getting to 2 billion was a major
watershed they're not finished and why
he's courting Xi Jinping the president
of China so to the extent of jogging
through Tiananmen Square which is an
extra without a gassman without a gas
mask very hazardous thing to do
so Metcalfe's law which actually was
formulated with respect to
telecommunications networks it's almost
a pre-internet idea says that a network
is more powerful the bigger it is and
this is also illustrated by what
happened to small exclusive networks
when they tried to wield power the
Illuminati may be accused as they were
from the 1790s of having caused the
French Revolution actually there were
way too few Illuminati to do anything
much and they were very easily closed
down there were a secret society
membership never got even to 2,000 and
the irony of the whole conspiracy theory
about the Illuminati is that it wildly
exaggerated s' their power here's
another example al-qaeda
looked like an incredibly effective
Network because it carried out the 9/11
attacks and a tremendously bright man
Valdis Krebs was the first person to
graph the network of the 9/11 plotters a
graph that I reproduce in the book
because it's through his work that
Mohammed Atta was a was identified as
the key 9/11 plotter but you may have
noticed that after that they didn't
really achieve a whole lot and that was
because the network really could only do
that
once it was too small it had been
designed to be kept relatively small in
order to maintain secrecy to do repeated
large-scale attacks whereas Islamic
state which is sought to be a big
Network and constantly trying to grow
itself not only on the ground but online
is actually a much more formidable foe
so I think small networks although
they're nice to belong to if you're
elected sir
I don't know the Apostles in Cambridge
you probably feel really rather in a
secret society that engendered a lot of
spies and 1930s Britain well there were
some other people who weren't spies who
were brilliant like let's let's not be
too oxford here they were all at
Cambridge I should add all right let's
be Oxford so one of the fun parts of the
book is the story of the Apostles
Mendeley exclusive and more or less not
that secret but somewhat secret at least
mysterious society of intellectuals in
Cambridge which produced amongst other
people John Maynard Keynes Lytton
Strachey both were members but in the
1930s this very exclusive network was
thoroughly and successfully penetrated
by the KGB Cambridge spies included
least three apostles and this is another
illustration of the problem with small
networks maybe the problem with networks
generally they're not very good at
defense so the Russians of a long
history of penetrating other people's
networks they did it last year to both
the Democrats and the Republicans let's
not forget and that that I think is a
really important thing to bear in mind
so no I don't think small is beautiful
for networks let's take another round of
questions I we have noticed that the
questions so far have all come from the
distinguished men in the audience I mean
they're that both sexes are represented
here so posies maybe you have her hand
up right there
very good okay could we get a number and
a mic to the lady there as well and
we'll take another get a microphone so
as may be one of the token Americans in
the audience you talked about the
networks that are controlled by
individuals in the US and the ones that
are controlled by the governments in
China you also just mentioned the
Russians and their involvement and I
think it's apparent paraphrasing of what
he said but Putin recently made a
statement about those who control these
networks meaning the Internet this kind
of technology control the future so I
would just wonder if you could talk a
little bit about what you see the
Russians role in all of this because
they obviously have had a big impact but
they're also a lot of focus on it at
this point in time so thanks very much
great question about the Russians Madame
and we'll get a couple more points in as
well do we have another number going on
there yes number one okay go ahead I was
just wondering if you think networks
have become more fickle in this day and
age it's very easy to follow and
unfollow someone in Twitter and if
that's had any more significant
behavioral impacts on society
thank you much excellent question let's
take one more in this round number two
right here go ahead you said earlier
that smaller networks are not as
powerful and that they don't achieve so
much but wouldn't be let's see the East
German of evolution then the East German
state came down and wouldn't this be an
example of smaller networks starting off
like in Leipzig Avanti Nikolay church
they started off and then it basically
spread out at that small network
achieved quite a bit didn't it explained
that was the network that eventually
became the German demonstrations against
the contract in 1989 leading ultimately
to the fall exactly start off with
smaller networks in smaller cities
around churches and then be connected to
each other but they were not massively
connected privacy but it was too
dangerous deed so I got three excellent
questions being terrific questions
Thanks Putin has a problem in fact he
has a whole bunch of problems problem
one is what looked like a brilliant
psychological warfare operation the
meddling in the u.s. election is back
fart massively on him so that relations
between the US and Russia are at an
all-time post Cold War low Lindsey
Graham remarked that it took some real
genius to unite Republicans and
Democrats in Congress
and they were United over tightening
sanctions on Russia problem too is you
know Russia's just not big enough to
build its own competitive network
structure it does have them but they
don't have the kind of critical mass
that China has so he's right to identify
that he who controls the networks will
control the 21st century it won't be him
the the Russian networks basically
outside of Russia subsist for nefarious
activities so if you get booted off the
the West Coast the Silicon Valley
networks then you end up going to the
Russian networks to do whatever
skulduggery you have in mind and so the
dark web is is partly a Russian Russian
venture but here's the trouble in the in
the world of cyber warfare which is an
extraordinarily important part of our
story that we haven't touched on the
ongoing constant conflict on the
internet between states and non-state
actors and companies in that world of
cyber warfare up until now the Russians
have essentially behaved like poachers
they have been to put it crudely outside
the tent running with the bad boys the
problem about that is that Russia really
is as likely to be hit by cyber warfare
as any major state and it was to my mind
deeply satisfying to read that the one a
crime malware had infected more
computers in Russia than any other
country and I think at some point Russia
is going to have to recognize that he
cannot simply be the renegade of the
great powers running around with the bad
actors on the internet it has to
recognize it's common interest in having
some kind of order in cyberspace and not
what we have at the moment which is a
kind of Anarchy or permanent state of
war just to say nailed that wanna cry
was an attack cyber attack earlier this
year against software of bureaucracies
of many countries including this one
originated in Russia well made it's
probably not actually it was actually a
morphed us piece of software we think
which essentially infected people who
hadn't updated their operating systems
and locked them out of their of their
hard drives and the Russians who if you
go to Russia don't necessarily always
have the best of software it's a little
bit like the NHS only it's a country
were affected almost as much as the NHS
and most of its most effective employees
are foreigners as it may have a lot in
common I can say this company because my
father worked all his life for the
National Service National Health Service
and often drew a parallel between it and
the Soviet Union least it didn't have
nuclear weapons
so networks is fickle
this is a really important point the
nightmare if you're Mark Zuckerberg is
in the following data in the demographic
under 30 more and more young people in
the United States are using snapchat in
preference to Facebook and that must
worry him almost more than the Russia
inquiry and all the attendant scandal
because if there were large-scale
defection by young users then Facebook's
future would start looking a lot less
bright so yeah the system is fickle but
the following is true in all of these
different networked markets winner takes
all
or winner takes nearly all that Eric
Schmidt puts this the chairman of
alphabet the parent company of Google in
the following way it's zip slaw Zee IPF
zips law and in zip slaw the winner gets
90 percent
some people get nine percent and the
rest get 0.9 percent and so at the
moment Facebook's the winner-take-all
just as uber seemed to be the winner
take all in the ride-sharing context
but that can change myspace looked like
it would win social networking myspace
was invented before Facebook but it's
lunch got eaten so yeah it's it's a
fickle volatile world and one argument
that is often made by these big network
companies when they are accused of being
monopolies is competition is just a
click away and that's become the
standard defense against the antitrust
suits that some people talk about
bringing against these companies finally
I'm very glad you asked about the
revolutions of 1989 I was in Germany in
1989 and you have to remember two things
one all networks by definition start
small Facebook was just a bunch of
Harvard students initially the key thing
is not the starting size it's the rate
of growth and the rate of growth of the
crowds in Leipzig was exponential I know
this because I did the numbers for a
book I wrote I think it was civilization
I even have friends who were there and
in Leipzig a good journalist friend of
mine was there and he said the scary
thing at the beginning of the leipzig
protests he was an early member of the
network was that the East German
security forces were there with weapons
and they were deeply afraid that the the
East German regime honaker's regime
would give the order and there would be
channel and square in leipzig but
because it grew very rapidly
exponentially in those few months became
a point when that was no longer a viable
option especially for a regime that had
essentially been told not to do it by
gorbachev i revisit the story of 1989 in
this book 1989 was in some ways the best
year of my life I look back on it and I
still I still marvel that I was there
and witnessed the disintegration of the
Berlin Wall that that year I wasn't
there on the night that it actually came
down
I was there during the summer I even
wrote a piece with the title the Berlin
Wall is crumbling because I was
observing so many people crossing over
into West Berlin from other East
European countries where the travel
restrictions had been loosened like
Poland but the the newspaper that I sent
it to refused to publish it and the
editor this was communicated to me by
the deputy editor he said well do the
editor feels you've been listening to
too many Ronald Reagan speeches so my
peace my prophetic peace was never
published and is lost to posterity
because it was only on a little tandy
which is the memory of the size of a
Nats memory in this book I look at the
way that networks of dissent formed in
the country that was much more important
than East Germany namely Poland and
there's some terrific work on this by
Polish scholar who's graphed all and
reconstructed all the different networks
that preceded solidarity and shown how
it was that solidarity for a brief but
crucial period was able to join together
all the different dissident forces which
range from the right devout Catholic
nationalists to the left liberal leaning
academics and intellectuals so bad
illustrates the point well Poland got
critical mass of dissident networks
first and it was there that the
Communists rule first folded thank you
deal and we've got another round of
questions now and I see hands and
numbers coming up there too okay let's
let's not do them in order we've got a
four over there I wanna make sure of
different parts of the whole get taken
up so for let's take that one first and
then make sure we go around all right
thanks very much
so I wonder how you think that we can
utilize this understanding of networks
specifically the Silicon Valley kind of
network to combat rather than encourage
Islamic terrorism okay that's a very
good question thank you for that
let's see is there a number that yes we
have a number three on this side let's
get number three
go ahead how do you think about the
relationship between hierarchy and
regulation and what do you think is the
most appropriate way to regulate
networks very good question thanks for
that and let's there's another for but
its way of the other side now so that's
good let's get that for hi you spoke
earlier about the hierarchy and the
network I was wondering if you had an
opinion on how the network seems to
almost need a hierarchy so if we look at
for example Wikipedia and how originally
it had no editors before becoming an
organization with editors and almost
peer-driven
or Facebook which now has groups and
group admins and various other levels of
hierarchy within its tools so the last
key questions both very good questions
almost related to each other and then
the question of course about Islamic
terrorism you well let me start with the
question on on Islamic terrorism and not
only terrorism but the the non violent
Islamic extremism which i think is a
precursor of a violent action my wife
ayaan Hirsi Ali has written an important
analysis of this showing how Dawa
frizzle at ization is the prelude to
jihad at the moment we're doing a pretty
terrible job of this in two respects one
the networks have not been very
effective at preventing their use by
groups like Islamic state and Islamic
state I described this in the book in
fact I show a network graph of Islamic
states blogging presence in 2013 prior
to the the high profile executions that
suddenly got everybody's attention the
following year and it's clear that
Islamic state continues to be able to
function even on major platforms by
playing whack-a-mole with the companies
you closed down one account and another
one opens
and there isn't in fact a good way of
dealing algorithmically
with the way these people operate and
this relates to the second and third
questions I'm going to talk about were
still what has happened in the last year
or so has been the those who speak out
against Islamic extremism are attacked
online relentlessly and viciously and
accused constantly of Islamophobia and
this brings me to the questions of
hierarchy and regulation and whether or
not networks need hierarchy and indeed
regulation the answer is they clearly do
they clearly do the problem is how
exactly do we regulate platforms with 2
billion users generating vast quantities
of content that are clearly beyond any
human editorial control at moments we
have seen to have reached a consensus in
the United States that these platforms
are not publishers they are Network
platforms and they continue to be
regulated differently from publishers of
content under the 1996 Communications
Decency Act this exemption means that
people at Facebook or for that matter at
Google and not responsible for what
appears on their platforms there's no
liability there's no responsibility to
warm this exemption puts them at a great
advantage relative to conventional
publishers who have those liabilities
under the law this is an anomaly it must
I think ultimately change if it doesn't
change we are going to arrive in a
situation at which publication is
essentially monopolized or near
monopolized by the Silicon Valley
companies who will claim to have no
responsibility for what is published and
then when we scream and shout as the
European Commission does and says but
you're publishing terrible things they
will
haier fact checkers and editors and put
up a show of trying to suppress whatever
they're told is hate speech this is a
completely dangerous path to go down by
the way because I think the European
Commission is giving even more power to
these platforms by telling them
effectively to be censors on our behalf
that seems to be the German government's
line I find it extraordinary but I think
we ultimately need to recognize that we
haven't solved this problem we're
nowhere close to solving it and I think
that this will be one of the major
challenges not only in the United States
but in Europe indeed everywhere in the
free world how do we regulate such vast
networks that have never existed on this
scale before if we don't regulate them
they clearly have power beyond the
imaginings of the most powerful press
baron as well as all the advertising
revenue in the world
the two companies Google and Facebook
got 90 percent of all new online
advertising in the fourth quarter of
2016 if you are not in that business if
you're in the conventional publishing
business you are dying at this point so
we haven't figured this out and that's
partly what motivated me to write this
book this is a huge problem and we don't
know what to do Democrats say let's
break them up they're monopolies let's
do antitrust like progressives used to
do and that doesn't get very far because
they're natural monopolies how do you
break up Google it's not conceivable
that you could have a sort of balkanized
search engine Google Arkansas
it's not gonna happen but if that's not
gonna happen then I think there's some
very hard thinking to be done about what
regulation these should be given
they are utilities the Supreme Court
Ronna recently said they are the public
square which was good for me since I'd
called my book already the square in the
tower this is the public square but who
owns it a very potent question with
which to leave the discussion for
tonight we could go on we probably ought
to go on for even longer but the clock
is defeating us before we finish the
formal part of the evenings though I
think we should acknowledge that we've
had a tremendous range of discussion not
just on an immensely intriguing
historical phenomenon the question of
hierarchies networks and how they're
related ranging from the Illuminati and
the Reformation all the way through
Henry Kissinger to the present day and
also a variety of reflections some of
them optimistic some of them frankly
alarming about where we may have been
going there were very few of any other
historians who could put this together
but Neil Ferguson is clearly very much
one of those we should thank him and
intelligence squared who have brought us
here tonight
and reminded that the book will be
available for signing in the foyer
immediately afterwards Neil Ferguson
thank you very much
[Applause]